The snark left discord is being massively overblown, okay? There's
like eight people there total who aren't worthless. But Destiny
has done so much worse to us.
He doxxed us.
You are so stupid. Destiny was doxxing people long before this
discord ever existed. You
>> Brief introduction of his POV.
What am I doing today? Okay, what are my goals? What are you
doing today? guys. What do I plan to do? So, I plan to kind of
showcase
what's
what the snarkers do,
how they do it,
the tactics they use. Because at the end of the day, I don't
have a complete set of information. I don't. I don't have access
to the logs or the discords or anything like that, right? I have
seen some information.
I have some pieces of the puzzle, but I don't have a complete
picture.
So, I can't make any specific
like
J Soc did this on this day at this time at this place, and he
sent this DM to that. I don't I don't I just don't have that.
I cannot make that claim, right?
Okay. What I just want to know what what evidence you do have.
That's like about it. Cuz it sounds to me like a picture of Vic
was put put somewhere, and he's lost his mind over it.
He thinks like that information being in that discord proves
that this discord has been like a nest of doxxing or something,
despite a bunch of people in there saying it's obviously not
that.
But hey, we keep going. >> What I can do, and what I think
will help, and what I think will hurt them, and it really will,
is point out how they operate.
And once you once once once it's made known to you, you're going
to see it everywhere, man. You're going to see it all over. Right?
Because they do it most of it in the open, right? They don't
make a secret of it. >> Okay. Right? And you'll see the
op. And when you see it, you'll be like, "Oh, a lot of things
will make sense." Right? A lot of things will make sense.
>> Because they prey on ignorance.
They're like little roaches.
They hide in the dark, okay?
I don't think that at all. Shining a light on what they do makes
it harder for them to do what they
Shining a light on what we do actually just gives us viewers
and followers and more power. So, thank you, Wick, for contributing
to the team. >> to talk about it. We're going to go through
it, okay? If I could see how if Wick thought that's what's happening,
that Wick would, in his head, think he's helping,
But we have the truth. We have the
The truth is on our side.
You know what I'm saying? So, if you send people to me and they
ask me questions and I just show them exactly why I might not
like somebody or what exactly I think somebody's done wrong,
I just win. I just win there. So, thank you. Please continue
shining a light, Wick. And me and Duce Highly Cyan,
or however you say your name, I do appreciate it. So, at the
end of the day, why am I doing this or what what was the catalyst?
If you haven't heard, I got doxxed, gang.
So, this isn't the first time I've been Right? Okay. >> But
the last time it happened, it happened like as a group.
Right? A bunch of us got all doxxed at the same time. So, it
felt little
it felt different, right? It felt different. And I knew it happened
when it happened. Right? I knew that okay, this happened, but
I can kind of I could kind of hide behind the larger creators
a little bit, right? And kind of keep it on the down low, and
not really
You could have kept it on the down low here. You just went and
and acknowledged it and yelled about it this time, right? Like
you This time you've just gone and yelled about it. This doesn't
help you. You could have kept your head down this time, too,
if you wanted to. But, it's fine.
If you If you have some If you think it's important to stand
up and say this happened to me,
>> talk about a little bit and kind of slide through. This
time feels different. And And one of the reasons is is not just
me that got targeted.
But, it's it was Tally. Um I talked to them and got permission
to say what I'm going to say, okay? We had a little powwow, okay?
And uh we decided it is better that people know
just how this has gone.
Um so, Tally got okay.
Stardust got
And for Tally, specifically,
uh they found her full name. Uh they found the place where she
works. Uh they found Dude, this is This is a truly insane thing
to do. I'm sorry.
There's no reason I feel bad for the people who have been
did to accept it doing this. This is a wild thing to start putting
out there on the record.
No Nothing by the way, nothing nothing here has been published
by that snark left group. None of it was even The things he's
describing currently were even found by that group, okay? The
thing that happened in the Discord, and I do think it was a tweet
that featured a picture of Wick and his name, and it was archived
by a bot. To pretend that this level of information gathering
was going on in the Discord is totally insane.
It was like somebody put a a tweet in, and I have no idea the
context, but like they deleted the message, and then once we
found out that that was put in there, we banned the person who
did it. It's It's insane. There's nothing close to what's happening
in other places, and we have nothing to do with that. So >> information
on her wife Or at least, you know, to my knowledge, we have nothing
There's not no connection at all, right? You would have to give
me an idea of a connection. I have no knowledge of any connection.
They
No, I I'm obviously not omniscient. If somebody has like a a
different username and is operating as an anonymous person in
a different place, I can't prevent that unless I'm told about
it. So if somebody has evidence of that, please reach out. >> released
her address of her workplace,
And they made it explicitly known that they were looking for
her home address on uh Zillow for a  complete doxx, right?
Um And they'd done this months ago,
I didn't know about it.
But But it happened. They want to keep us from talking in the
One of the biggest, I guess, weapons that the snarkers and snarker-adjacent
communities have
besides anonymity,
right? They It They They We're going to talk about one of the
core concepts we're going to talk about is plausible deniability
and how they operate in kind of like a cellular structure and
how they operate like a They have cross-pollinated communities.
This is why nobody intelligent is on board anymore, right? Because
you essentially have to operate in a way You have to tell this
story that requires a level of oversight over communities
that is impossible in the internet, like entirely impossible,
right? We can't go around and figure out what other Discords
every person in a Discord is in, right? Like it's Like you want
me to stop somebody who's under an anonymous username from making
a different anonymous account and operating somewhere else, or
be aware of it. How the is that possible, buddy?
Um I do want to, before we get into the meat, because this happened
uh this happened after I made my outline, but I wanted to insert
it because it's worth talking about.
Um, let's talk about Counter-Points.
Counter-Points should not have done what he did. Um,
going out in public and
basically putting other people's business on blast like that
was very inappropriate. And that's even dis- That That's even
We're not going to do any analysis of that situation at all.
Are we not going to do Not even a little bit. Not a Not even
a tiny bit of analysis of that situation.
Okay. Dude, we have to actually go back and watch it because
some people are suggesting that what happened was Connor was
referencing the Lauren stuff in a way that could go back to the
2022 leaks or 2023 leaks, whenever that was. Right? People are
suggesting that that's what Connor was referring to. Like he
was He was doing it in an in an ambiguous way,
right? That couldn't be blamed on him. And then Destiny leaked
the dating currently. If that's how it went, then Connor wasn't
leaking public stuff. It was Destiny leaking that publicly, right?
At least with regards to Lauren.
Being it from it from like the streamer drama, the the friendship
dynamics there, right? Putting out like other
well, escapades and
um,
statuses on blast just because you're mad at a friend and you
want to hurt him with it, all the while saying that you're doing
it as a tough love tactic,
you're you're turning other people's business into like a a weapon,
man, into a bullet. It's highly inappropriate.
That's just not something you do.
Into [__] You don't You don't talk to friends like
that in public. Why did Destiny lie about his relationship with
Lauren Southern to try to get an own on Connor in that conversation?
You don't talk to friends like that in public.
I just I literally don't get it. I and there's this weird
Dude, should we just go like fully skits? So this is weird psychopathic
thing Destiny I think does. Man, I it's hard for me to show you
perfect proof of this. I think he quite often lets people know
things in private in a way that they have to dance around it
in public and he will even press on them to dance around it in
public, right? Like he will let people know things in private
that they shouldn't have shared or they shouldn't share and then
he will intentionally make an argument trying to pressure them
into like basically saying, well, you could totally beat me if
you reveal the truth right now. You totally beat beat me if you
reveal the truth right now. Will you? Will you? Will you or won't
you? Will you or won't you? Will you or won't you? It's It's
straight up psychotic [__]
It's wild. It's anyway.
And we won't get a commentary on that either from Wick, okay?
Cuz Wick is in the Destiny's a massive victim here. Destiny is
the eternal
God. Like this isn't This isn't like a something you do with
a friend in public. You If that had been a private conversation
that they had, where he wanted to be like, man, you're [__]
up your life cuz you're doing XYZ. You
What are you doing, man? Like there or is this like you I can
see instances
where that would be entirely appropriate
that where it might even be the right thing to do, right? Um
and again, I don't I don't know in their entire dynamic, so please
keep that you know, take it with a grain of salt, right? I don't
I don't know their
uh I don't know the truth claims of what he was claiming and
what he wasn't, right? I don't know. But yeah, you don't do that
[__] in public. That's just not okay. That's just
not okay, man. What's going on? But I get it, like a lot of pressure.
Um there's a lot of different incentives. There's a lot of different
um people pushing you one direction or another. And that on top
of the personal [__] you're going through, again,
give some grace. But I still kind of like this this It's kind
of gross. Uh it felt gross. I tried to stop it. Uh I tried to
get the I tried to calm down. I tried to kind of
get everyone to de-escalate
This is, by the way, how like this Destiny's favorite situation
where he has like so- some friends who don't know the whole truth
that Connor does, and they're all putting themselves out there
in a way that they would be totally humiliated if the full truth
comes out.
Like they're totally defending him. They have no idea what happened
with Connor, what set him off. And Destiny's got them all right.
This is like his ideal scenario right now, right? He's got so
many friends who if they hear the whole truth, they'll be totally
humiliated. They could be totally humiliated in
And he's like got other people who knew part of the truth, and
now the friends who know nothing are attacking the people who
know the truth. Further pressuring them to tell the truth.
And Destiny just has to sit back and
Uh just to summarize kind of like the intro portion here, cuz
I'm getting a little long-winded. Uh people need to understand
what tactics are being used, so you can see and understand how
how none of this is is real in a real sense. None of it's real
It's all fake and gay, to to borrow a phrase. Um these are all
astroturfed, though.
Like you're you're straight up lying. >> narratives that
are going around. These are all Like they make it look like it's
organic, and people are just naturally feeling this way, but
no, they're not. These are talking points that are manufactured,
that are boosted, that an organization like like with organizations
are clipping and shipping
all of this
Clipping and shipping.
Or it's like 100 people. Well, like four of them are not
I'm sorry.
This The Snark Left Discord is being massively overblown, okay?
There's like eight people there total who aren't worthless. Holy
sh-
How are we PRETENDING THIS? WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT right now?
I'm just kidding, by the way. Lots There's 100 totally loyal,
totally psychopathic
mujahideen soldiers, okay? Obviously, but Come on, man.
This is so It's We have to be blown up into something that's
so crazy. We're like 1/10,000
the Clavicular Operation.
What are we talking about, man? This is astroturfed in a very
real way, and we're going to get to that. Um I want to talk about
who's at fault.
This is one of those things where I can't give you solid answers
because I don't know. And I want to make that clear what I'm
saying and what I'm not saying. I have suspicions
based on the evidence that I have seen. There's a couple people
who I know, but uh you don't get to know that information yet.
Uh but for like other people,
it's just suspicion at this point,
but I am fairly confident
that [snorts] as more information comes out, some of my suspicions
will be will be confirmed. But I just want to make sure that
everyone knows that I'm not making any
accusations against specific people unless I say their specific
name, okay? So if you're sitting there thinking, "Why is he attacking
me?"
There's this evil amorphous blob, dude.
I There's got to be like a like a fantasy or anime reference
here, okay?
Like There's this amorphous invisible blob that just attacks
attacks streamers, guys, and it's like all powerful, but I'm
not blaming anybody for it. >> Dude. Did I say your name?
Then, I mean, maybe if you're part of these groups,
uh but I don't know if you're part of these groups or not. Does
that make sense?
We got it? We're on the same page here? Um one of the biggest
pieces of the puzzle that I've received
is when
Destiny and Dan and Mouton and all those people were saying,
"Hey,
this server has has a doxx in it. Has doxxes in it."
And the people who were
>> snark team and the snark side kept saying, "No, they
don't. No, you're lying. That's not true. We don't
I use This is the lowest IQ trap to fall into, man. This is exactly
why I'm like So, I try to be so careful, man, cuz they think
this is like good proof of anything, right? I'm going to make
a universal claim.
I'm going to I'm I'm going to force you to make some universal
claim. This has never happened. Even though it's obvious you
could never say that this has never happened, even though anybody
with an above room temperature IQ can see that if you say, "I've
never been somewhere where people have been doxxed." That means
I've never seen someone get doxxed anywhere I've ever been. Like
this never happened,
Even though everybody knows that, and they go, "Oh, well, look
at this." It's like, dude, one message was deleted, so not even
searchable. Like It's There's so many things going on with regards
to the the tweet that Wicks referring to, right?
Like the the lowest IQ
total mouth-breathing
waste of existence. This fools them. This this tricks them.
Dude, it's so dumb. That's why I have to try to keep doing the
"Oh, to my knowledge, not to my knowledge. Oh, as far as I know."
Because if I If I say
then I could get clipped somewhere like saying something they'll
go, "Oh, look. This guy said that nobody ever typed the hard
R in in that Discord, but here's a log from 8 months ago where
where where it happened." It's like, "Well, okay. Well, it's
deleted. I couldn't search for it." Do you know what I mean?
It's a totally insane bar for people to be speaking at.
And for the other side, it's like, "We have real substantial
evidence of
actual wrongdoing that causes actual harm in the world."
Anyway, that's people we have no doxxes in my in our server.
None of that's true. Silly combo. I was shown evidence. Destiny
was telling the truth. And the people who were telling me that
the snark server had none of this and that were lying. And
it caused me to reevaluate my priors,
And the credibility of Destiny has shot up in my estimation.
It's just shot up. He was He was just correct. This is just true.
What he said was just true, and I know it.
the people who told me that there was nothing in the snark server,
their credibility is shot with me. I'm like, "I don't trust you
anymore." And some of these people I trusted.
You just wanted to be on that side. It's totally fine, but it's
obvious you just wanted to be on that side, Wick. Like you're
just embarrassing yourself with this. You You just want to be
on that side, which is whatever. Okay, you You're too stupid.
This is a lot of the other thing going on is people are like
stale. They just want to be with like the biggest bully who they
think will win, right? They don't really have the capacity to
evaluate information or make informed decisions of their own.
So, they find the guy who's the just the biggest bully, who's
bullied everybody else, who's won every time before, and they're
going to ride with that guy. Right? Like they've watched these
manifestos drop before, and you see this in DGG, right? Manifestos
coming is just trust the plan. Or like
>> for whatever the Destiny community has become, okay?
It's just trust the plan. And yeah, he's just going to he's going
to stick with the big bully that's won on this on this kind of
conflict before. He's not going to look into who's right. He
doesn't care. He just wants this side to win. And realistically,
I'm guessing a lot of the rest of this stream is going to go
into his reasoning for that, which is he got bullied by like
spicy chatter or something. Like he really That's probably what
it is. Like he got bullied by some spicy chatters who made fun
of him, made fun of his teeth, made fun of him taking 2 years
to go and go to the dentist and get his teeth fixed. And that's
going to be what pushed him in this direction.
Like the only thing that pushed him in this direction.
I'm not joking. It It is that simple. It is that pathetic. It
is that sad.
That's just it. did Right? I really did. I was like, man, okay.
Your word? I'll take your word.
I'll take your word. And that's why like I was skeptical. I was
keeping neutral cuz I had competing people who both I I had some
level of trust for um were telling me different things. I was
like, okay. I don't know. I haven't seen it. But no, it's like
after seeing
Uh yeah. I feel like this is This is what I'm trying to communicate,
Dobby. Yes, it's about the other side wronging him on a personal
level. And so he doesn't like them, doesn't want to be with them.
So he's always wanted to be on that side. And this finally gives
him some like explanation he can give other people. Unfortunately,
a lot of the other people who care and look into things, they
can all see exactly what's going on. >> Seeing that, yeah.
Okay. This person was tell This person was honest with me, was
up front with me, and this person was a
Crazy work.
Puzzle pieces coming to place. Click. Click. Click.
There are three main concepts that I think that we have to uh
we have to under Well, four main concepts, I should say, that
we have to
Huh? One of them, the first I I I I want you to understand so
that you can understand the tactics and understand the space
and understand how these works, is how legitimate
can become illegitimate in certain contexts, Okay? How an action
that would normally be just fine, nothing wrong with it, it's
just how it is, when paired with other legitimate actions, can
turn into something sinister. Uh An example, driving in your
car, just
Totally fine if you're a white person, totally wrong if you're
a black person. Right, Wick? Let's go. >> places as long
as you abide the speed limit, who cares, right? Um obey the rules
of the road, you're fine. But when you have 10 cars all driving
and coordinating together to block a
and slow down traffic, that's different. Each of the individual
actions that these people are doing perfectly
But the coordination
and their goals and how they use the actions becomes illegitimate.
Does that make sense?
I'm immediate counter example.
There's nine people doing it instead of 10. One of them is stuck
in the gridlock around those 10, right? Can you use an RPG to
blow up that car?
Right? Cuz this is again the whole thing that's happening here
is they're basically blaming they're they're saying coordination
is happening because they feel like some certain groups work
together. That they feel like the output is the outcome that
they're seeing in their lives is negative and caused by these
groups in aggregate. So they think, well, you guys are coordinating.
That is not necessarily like that's not that doesn't even remotely
follow,
That's just not the case. That's doesn't even remotely follow.
So then you have to ask, is it okay to attack anybody who you
perceive just because of your perception of them being involved
in that outcome? Is that is that okay? Like if I get punched
in the face and it's captured in like a TikTok short and people
laugh at it, are those people who laugh at it, can I hit one
of them back? Can I find one one person who left a comment going,
"Ha, I love watching this guy get hit in the face." Can I go
and hit that person in the face? Right? There has to be some
way of mapping someone's actions onto the consequences for those
actions.
But I think they are explicitly endeavoring to like disconnect
these things. Another analogy. I got a few. I wrote a couple
down. Uh light a match, okay? You light a match uh to light your
cigarette, uh light a candle, um if it's dark out and you want
to get some light. Nothing wrong with that, right?
Perfectly legitimate.
Perfectly fine. Nothing will happen. But if you light a match
next to a gas
even though it's the same action, because it's done in a different
environment, in a different context, you have a different result.
And the snarkers have been pumping
pumping gas into every chat room, every voice call, every comment
section,
normal normal actions, normal things, suddenly have explosive
results.
Apparently we dude. And they'll hide behind the legitimate portion,
right? Or the the legitimate thing. They'll They want you to
focus on the bricks, so you can't see the wall, okay? And they'll
hide behind that. They'll That's the tactic that they'll do,
right? Um that they'll say, "Well, anyone can drive. I'm just
driving, man. There's nothing wrong with driving. Are you trying
to stop my right to drive?" Of course I could just drive. I'm
just a Ameri- like I'm a citizen, right? I am a citizen of the
internet. We could all just drive, right? But they're all doing
it together to block you, right? They're all driving to block
you in.
Um uh none of this is a thing of All of the people who dislike
me are ACTING IN COORDINATION. Nobody could possibly There's
no way this many people could like could dislike me without it
being coordinated. Better one a better analogy would be something
like shooting a mugger compared to carrying a weapon to shoot
a specific person before you knew they were going to mug someone.
Well, there there's a lot of analogies we need to discuss. So,
those are the ones I chose. Maybe there's better ones, but those
are the ones that I went with,
We're not going to be perfect here today. But yes, they And they'll
mock it, too. Like, "This guy's just talking about This guy's
just talking about All he's All we're doing is a It's a clip
channel, bro. It's a clip channel. That's all it is. That's all
It's just a clip channel."
Which is fine in normal contexts, but when it's coordinated,
targeted, edited out of context, meant to meant to target specific
people for a specific purpose, uh meant driven and boosted and
all these things, it can become harassment.
Show me that. Even though Show me that now, Wick. Show me that
now. the context around it, why you're doing it, to what purpose,
to what end
can become harassment.
um so yeah, that's a concept that I think you need to understand
the first two, how legitimate actions can become illegitimate
in different contexts, and how coordination matters.
They want every step judged in isolation because each step sounds
defensible in isolation. But harassment campaigns are not built
out of one giant indefensible act. They are built out of many
small defensible acts arranged towards an indefensible purpose.
Example, a streamer makes a messy comment during a free hour
broadcast. A hostile viewer clips 15 seconds of it. That viewer
posts it in a server dedicated to attacking that streamer. The
server agrees uh the server uh like they they do like they're
They manufacture talking points, agrees on the harshest possible
interpretation. The members of that server begin posting the
clip with similar captions, uh similar hashtags, all these things.
Members begin um sending it out to other streamers that may or
may not be not be connected right? I want I do want to get into
another core concept later, the and another tactic they use,
the plausible deniability, the they use unrelated actors to further
their goals uh as part of the machine even though these other
unrelated actors do not realize that they are part of the machine,
right? Um the they go in and they react to it into the context
of it as if it's already settled, right? Like this is obviously
what it means. Um there is no other interpretation. If you have
another interpretation, you're stupid, etc. And then people will
go in and send people into these chats of streamers reacting
to it that may or may not be part of the machine, or the streamers
themselves that they're clipping to stir, right? To get reactions
for more clips, to uh spread it even around anymore, to kind
of create this this narrative that they can use to serve their
purpose, right? And all of And all of these acts by themselves
might be defensible in different contexts, right? Well, there's
nothing wrong with clipping people. There's nothing wrong with
giving your opinion. There's nothing wrong with reacting to and
giving a take like Wick sucks, the Wick handled that bad, right?
There's nothing wrong uh even bad about boosting your friends.
Like if your friend wants you to boost their clip, nothing wrong
with that in isolation.
Right? But it's the coordination. And they'll start tagging the
streamer's guests. They'll start sending it to the streamer's
sponsors and say, "Is this your boy? Look at what your boy said
about Israel Pal Tide. You're going to You're going to let him
say that?" What? And when the streamer gets angry or defensive
because they'll see it
that's clipped, too. And it's used to push, right? The narrative,
stress the target out so that they make mistakes, and it's a
whole system. Okay? And remember, this is the
Love the Snark Server. They have targets.
It's not just Destiny, by the way. Ethan Klein, uh few others.
They've targeted Hutch, they've targeted Loaded Box, I believe.
Um I don't I don't know the full target list. I don't have access
to the logs, right? But they have targets. I again,
are we pretending that the entire Twitch anti-Semitism thing
didn't happen or what Like, you're literally just describing
the Twitch anti-Semitism campaign, directly, one-to-one. They
like perfect description of the Twitch anti-Semitism campaign.
Like, directly,
with no substitutes whatsoever.
They weren't just going after Hasan, they were going after the
people around
Dan going around like showing everybody the caller, doing the
research, take you to Loaded Box, take you to Hutch. What What
are you guys mad? Are Are Are you guys mad about like copyright
infringement, IP infringement? What is the What is the allegation?
You guys are doing the thing we do, and we really hate it. Like,
okay. I Okay. Cry about it. Targets. And they are targeting them.
They targeted me.
So, that's that's how it's happening, right? And again, they'll
retreat to the They'll want every aspect judged in isolation,
and they'll retreat to that, and they'll be like, "Bro, we're
just clipping. What's wrong with clipping?" Because it hides
and obfuscates the scale of what they're doing and the real purpose
of what they're doing, which is to harass and jaywalk. And yes,
I'm naming names, has called for the mass reporting of different
targets. And that's a lie, or show where I've called to mass
report somebody other than
You just said different targets. I've called for the mass reporting
of different targets. What? And he has used this system of harassment
and coordination to create the justification Do him? No, it's
just >> where he can call for that, where he makes others
feel justified in taking that action. I can't give you the details
of every single thing that he's done to do that. But he has admitted
to that to calling for the mass reporting of people. And you
have to remember
Destiny. Just Destiny.
And it took I like the bar is so insanely high. I've explained
where the bar is, and nobody would actually be upset or disagree
with that bar.
That's the problem. Right? That this is the goal, okay? The goal
isn't to get to the truth. They aren't mass reporting because
they've done something right.
Because they've organically done
They're mass reporting
The [__] What should happen? They've done something
right.
Because they've organically
done something
Sorry, just the way that came out was so
They're mass reporting because they hate
They hate them. So, they're building a permission structure.
They're building
Okay, it's so annoying to me that you guys will just It's Okay,
this actually does piss me off. This is the way you start me.
If you just watch my stream and repeat back every single one
of my arguments, but try to make them about me without understanding
why I was making them or without any of the conduct being similar,
that is actually a way to start me, okay? When you go and take
every argument I've had and throw it back at me with no underlying
factual basis,
Stop. Stop.
>> to say why what they are doing against the people that
they hate is righteous and just.
It's a coordination campaign.
It's what it is. It's AstroTurf. It's like um it's like
Trump sending out
>> uh to all the people in
uh the group chats on Maga side um after his like third assassination
attempt that they we have to build the ballroom. Okay? They want
it to feel
But it's not. It's AstroTurfed. It's not organic at
And remember a lot of each each of the people individuals in
this this server
not all of them share the same level of guilt. And I want to
make that clear, right? Um
if you're just in the server, who the [__] cares?
I don't.
But if you've been part of this coordination, if you've been
involved
to certain degrees, the more involved you are the more culpability
I feel that you have. Bleak. Bleak, man. Extremely >> uh
thank you for the example. Uh GregZ2 says Wictor V, if there
are levels to it, what level of culpable are you are you for
Destiny and DGG doxing? So, I guess we're going to We have a
couple more core points to get to you, but this is a good example
of one of the major main tactics that Nux Taku uses. Um asking
you why you're criticizing something if it's an internal critique.
If you just want to do an internal critique, that's fine. If
you want to say, but you to to specify that it's an internal
critique, Wictor would have to go, "Well, I don't have a problem
with my friends doing it. I only have a problem with my enemies
doing it cuz they say they they don't want to do it."
I'm just making a hypocrisy point, right? If that's all you want
to do, to an internal critique of their position, it shows inconsistency
on their part.
Then you have to you have to differentiate yourself and say,
"No, no, no, I disagree with that. I think this is okay."
That's what you have to say. Address both sides of it and it's
fine. Always, always, always be on offense.
If someone is talking about what you're doing, what about Destiny?
And And people are going to react to this. And this is This is
what they will say. Right? The I will make an accusation. I will
speak about what they're doing in the I don't want doxxing happening
around me. I don't want I don't want to be in communities with
people who doxx with any frequency. I disavow it. I do think
there's some capacity for people to change. Like if they've if
they've done something like post some [__] a year
ago, two years ago, three years ago, depending on like obviously,
I would never want somebody around who has, hmm, how would I
put it? I personally, yeah, I think there's like a sliding scale
there on forgiveness, but it's an immediate ban. It's an immediate
disavowal. And we never let that stuff stay. I think there was
an example in my Discord of like somebody who'd put someone's
name in the chat cuz they were in a relationship. And they like
broke up, and it was really messy. And after a year, I think
we unbanned that guy. I'm okay with that. They're They like talk
now, and it's like not a big deal. That's okay. That Like I'm
okay with
Probably the The closest I've come to breaking this is the Shamu
thing. But the Shamu thing's a little different in that I understand
he was in a space where that was like on the the table, a part
of the playing field in that space, which I think is gross, but
he left and doesn't want to do that anymore, right? It's a very
different thing. Yeah. Anyway, that's how I feel about it. >> The
The wrongs that they are doing, the the bad things that they
are doing. And wait for it, and you'll hear it. What about Destiny?
What about DGG? What about all these other people? What about
everything else? And it's a way to always, always, always be
on offense because they want you to listen Just do both sides
of it. Like I don't I don't want that [__] around
me. I want those people banned. I want those people not around
me at all, right? But now
that I've I've I've defended my side of it, right? Cuz I don't
think you should ever be scared of defending your side. Sometimes
if somebody's weaponizing that disingenuously, right? If they
never, ever, ever want to speak on it, they never, ever, ever
want to speak for what their, you know, their people do, or what
their their community does, or what they do personally, they
only want to attack, that's when it's bad.
But I'm totally fine explaining like my position, how I feel
about it. Litigating and Connor counterpoints to this I don't
know if he did this on purpose or just he just mind raped as
Destiny likes to say. Um instead of talking about what the snarkers
were doing he wanted to litigate Destiny's
What does that have anything to do with what we are talking about?
Nothing. But I The reason that Connor got onto Destiny's life
is because Destiny was
what you're you're only litigating things bad decisions I made
years ago. Destiny knows that Connor knows about incredibly risky
behavior he was engaging in as of I believe it's November 2025
and then as of a week ago or two weeks ago.
Wick, you
That is what Connor was upset about was he was saying he was
litigating something and trying to leave Destiny off the hook
and Destiny's going, "All this is in the past. All this is in
the past. Why are you so crazy, Connor? Why are you like losing
your mind right now?" When Destiny knew fully well why Connor
was upset in this precise moment in time.
That's what it was. You're acting like for no reason Connor brought
this up. You are not even remotely analyzing the reason for it.
Why would that be? Why would you want to so so desperately run
from the truth, the fact of the matter?
One can only speculate. People feel the need to defend themselves.
People feel the need to be like answer to explain. But if you're
excusing, you're losing. In the red court war, right? So, that's
the first tactic. Always always always always always always always
attack. Never ever ever ever make the conversation about what's
happening on the doxing server or the snark server or with Jstark
or with all these other I've like explicitly just done all of
these things. Oh, I would love to know what's happening with
me cuz I've I've literally gone and explained what
specifically.
I've no problem explaining what happened. The people always always
always always make the conversation what about Destiny? What
is Destiny doing? What is DGG doing? That's the first and most
important tactic that I need you guys to understand. I need you
to understand it. And this isn't a conspiracy.
By the way, if you're going to get mad about me reporting, I'm
afraid the conversation does have to go to what Destiny's doing.
You'd be a to not understand that. F.I. Douching Maliciousness
says, "What is Destiny doing?" Right now, Wick, you're streaming,
but what is Destiny doing? Oh, that's a good question. I have
no [__] clue. F.I. Douching the Witches Persona says,
"Classic Darvo, the same as Maga, just replace Destiny with Biden."
True.
Oh, also, another really important point is is like you can't
disconnect this from Destiny and Dan being the people leaking
these logs, right? So, when Wick says, "Well, I can see pieces,
but I can't see the whole picture."
Okay, so you're just taking their word for it? You can't rely
on Destiny and Dan's word and then say, "Well, don't talk to
me about what Destiny said or You can't do that.
Right? Obviously, that is of another just incredibly dim-witted
position to have. Um I'm going to take these people's word for
something, but if you ask me about their conduct, I'm not going
to be I'm going to say that you're just attacking them. You're
like trying to what about to them. No, Wick, your allegation
is based substantially on their word, taking their word for it.
So, like I'll give you I'll give you an
You have a factory owner who's who's built a machine, okay, or
who's helped to build a machine.
They may not personally operate the machine, but if he designed
the factory, if he ignored the safety warnings, if he rewarded
speed over caution, if he punished people who complained about
it, He like chat GPT together a whole thing here. Very cool.
Very, very cool.
Uh I Wait. Wait, wouldn't this Hold on. I I don't want to say
it before I think about it. Wait, let me let me go back here.
I'll give you I'll give you an analogy. Hold on. Let me listen
to this again. who's built a machine, okay, or who's helped to
build a machine.
They may not personally operate the machine, but if he designed
the factory, if he ignored the safety warnings, if he rewarded
speed over caution, if he punished people who complained about
it, he be Oh, it's the infinite machine. It's literally the infinite
work I didn't want to say it before I could go back and listen
to it again, but he's describing President Sunday's infinite
work machine hypothetical.
That's very funny.
Bro, it's
Do you think they just took like the transcripts of a bunch of
people's streams and put them into chat GPT and were like, "Figure
out how to like make these same allegations back at at the people
who are who are putting them out here." Or figure out how to
use the same rhetoric these people are. Like I I'm It's honestly
weird. It's uncanny to watch. bears responsibility when the machine
eventually hurts someone. And I'm not claiming that every central
figure in all this personally did every bad act. That would be
an absurd standard, okay? That that We would never meet that
standard, right? Like Trump didn't personally go in and break
in on January 6th, but he still bears
And this is a tactic that I'm going to show you, right? Because
I have I have I have an example of, right? And this is what we're
going to talk about Queen.
Okay, I'm sorry.
This This is where I'm going to say, "You cannot say that I'm
the person doing the bad things and that Queen's out and he's
innocent and he did nothing bad." You cannot do that while using
Queen's comments on you to attack that server or denigrate me,
okay? No. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Off. I'll
tell you anything Queen said that's mean or is like use it maliciously
weaponizing a definition, I won't cut him off for it. If I If
you want me to bring it up with him the next time I talk to him,
I'll ask him precisely what he means and I'll
But that's as far as I'll go. I'm not cutting him off for being
mean to people. I'm not cutting him off for maliciously using
a definition to [__] with somebody or make a joke,
okay?
But I will I will clarify with him exactly what he means
if you ask me to. How you doing?
Uh Schrödinger's joke.
What is Schrödinger's joke? It's where you make a statement,
say something, you mention a thing, and whether or not it's a
joke depends on how it lands.
So, this is a one of their favorite tactics that they'll do.
Especially now that they've been caught Oh, okay. Especially
now that we have the logs. You guys remember Nikondros uh during
the Chud Logic Destiny uh Shamoo debate, right? Before they actually
had the conversation and the logs were just released to Twitter,
that was the go-to for Nikondros. He's like, "It's just a joke,
gang. It's just a joke. We're just joking. We're having a good
time. It's a joke. I was posting it as a joke. It was a joke,
gang. It was a
I think he said that to me cuz he was like embarrassed in the
Discord. He didn't say that like out in public, right? He said
that in the Discord. >> It was a joke. It was a joke.
Because it's a it's it's where they live. It's a Schrödinger's
joke. Like if that hadn't worked, if people had bought that it
was a joke, that would have been the line. But no one bought
the joke because it was obviously not in the context of what
we had and it didn't go well for him. Nikondros was exposed as
a [__] liar, right? He he was obviously
But they live in this this space, right? It's Schrö-
Again, you were accusing him of doxxing. No information's been
posted anywhere. That person hasn't even been contacted. Like
literally nothing happened. I don't You are You are inventing
something.
Whole claws.
How you are allowed to do this without being called out is beyond
me. Schrödinger's joke, where they can say whatever they like
about you. They can make any claim that they want. I'm now so
annoyed that Chud didn't pull me into that convo.
And if people call them out or disprove their claim,
Oh, it's just a joke. I was just joking. We were just joking.
Let me show you one example, okay? Give me one moment. Let me
make sure I have it up. Here we go. Okay. Here is QueenMan. He
did a little I don't know why he posted me in response to what
Destiny tweeted, but this is me as a pretty kitty. Okay? I'm
a pretty kitty wig. First of all, uh just as an aside, um I don't
know why you guys think you're going to embarrass me for posting
things that I've posted publicly. Like if I was embarrassed about
this, I wouldn't have done it. I don't know I don't know what
you think you're going to do here. Like yes, I dressed up as
a
That's a part of the humiliation, by the way. That's a That's
like a part of them mocking you. Like you understand that, right?
They understand you're not embarrassed of it and that's a part
of the joke. That's like that's literally required for if you
were embarrassed by this that you could go, "Oh, I was just drunk
and I [__] this up and and it wouldn't be as funny."
The fact that you're willing to go, "Actually, this was awesome.
I love this. I love doing this and this is cool and I'll do it
again." That's a part of the joke. You forget it's just it was
funny. I was a great actor, okay? I was very pretty kitty. This
doesn't embarrass me. But there's something like I don't mind.
Like if you're going to like post me eating ramen noodles or
dancing or whatever. Whatever. I don't give a [__]
It's sometimes annoying depending, but whatever.
But that's not all they do. Um let me show you something. This
was from a couple years ago that Queenman did. Um
Hold on.
I'm just going to point out
very obvious that Wick referring to me saying I'm doing all these
evil things and you're going to catch me. I don't know how you're
doing that
when at the same time you're going to throw up like Queenman
clips saying, "Look at Look at how they Look at the tactics."
I need examples for me, man, that demonstrate >> And examples
to match your multiple examples you described. And the joke and
and and remember the defense for this has always been, "It's
just a joke." Wick, it's just a joke, right? But they only make
that defense when I like when I call it out. When I'm not calling
it you're talking to people in DMs. They're going around and
spreading the rumor that this is actually happened. So let me
just read the tweet and we'll watch the clip. So uh this is me
replying to Queenman and I say, "Hey, here's your audience painting
me out as someone who engages in assault against a woman. Lying
to your audience despite that same woman later making it clear
to folks that this was absolutely not the case." And not just
later, she was doing it at the time, too, right? He's going to
show one part of a chat, but he won't show the rest. We're going
to get to that. Um and then when he's called out on it, he retreats
to just jokes. Note that this is just one part of an active campaign
to slander me and paint me to have to be a suspect because this
isn't all they've done. This isn't all Queenman has said on this.
And he said stuff recently, too, on his stream about me and Kinetic
Kel, right? That's what he's done. Um he's a liar, and and worst
of all he's British. So, I don't know what the [__]
he's doing trying to make fun of me. He's British. It's crazy.
Take the L, mate. Uh, let's bring up actually some terrible allegations.
Yeah, let's let's watch the clip. Just watch the clip, and you
can see >> Wow, British. He's so British. He's so British.
Got him. Got him. But, you got him. There's actually some terrible
terrible allegations.
Absolutely horrific stuff, I got to say, that's been brought
up about about Wicks, I'll honestly say. So, Bucks wanted to
spin pressing for information. Let's go. >> At Ginger Marshall,
did Wicks ask for consent prior to groping yourself? >> And Madame
Genevieve in that photo that was posted. As you can see here,
if we get some zoom and enhance analysis going on. You can see
here Wicks is touching what appears to be
Madame Genevieve Touching people's legs that you're at a party
with and your friends with. Crazy. But, here's how they paint
it. >> He's outer thigh and knee. And that yeah, this is
this is the outer thigh here as well. The outer thigh and knee
on Ginger Marshall. Now
we've got the response here. He did not He did not ask. He did
not say, "Ma'am, would you mind if I touch your leg?" before
Who does that with friends? First of all. But, you see how they're
painting it? All right? And you see how they're clipping Ginger
Marshall and what she said? And we're going we're going to go
to what else she said, and we're going to talk about how this
obviously was not a joke. It was Schrödinger's joke, right? Because
it's a joke when you call them out on it, but they're actively
spreading this rumor, right? They're actively spreading this
rumor. But, yeah. Would you touch her leg? Now
is the sexual harassment HR meme? It is. It is. I said, "Tell
me you wouldn't be traumatized if Wicks touched your leg." Come
on, who here Who here can say
Who here can say they would not be traumatized if Wicks if Wicks
touched their leg, okay? An hour-long shower and then therapy.
I'd be traumatized if Destiny or Wicks did that, says Eddie.
I feel sick, says Hey, It's Lissie. I'd have eight showers. I'm
just laughing at how uh Creamy's got no gravitas back here. Creamy's
like is such a low power level right now. It's very funny listening
to the clip like this. Just no power level. No There's nothing
going on here. It's like watching I'm laughing because it's it's
like watching my old streams, right?
It's very funny. >> different loofahs.
Okay. [snorts] Endless hot showers and years of PTSD, especially
bare leg. Yeah, I mean that's just terrifying stuff. Really,
that's just nasty.
And it's hidden within jokes, right? The accusation itself is
hidden within kind of laughter.
No, it's not. The jokes are literally even even like like platonic
normal touching for people with is disgusting coming from you.
That's the joke. You are gross. You are gross to the level that
platonic normal touching actually seems like off-putting. It's
the HR meme is in when a hot guy does it, it's totally fine.
When an ugly guy does it, it's actually gross. Hello? Hello?
That's It's obvious the whole time that it's a joke. I hope they
got better than that. These are serious allegations, right? They're
joking, quote unquote, but they're not. Um that I'm a someone
who's harassed these women. And look, maybe you could say that
if this was isolated, but remember Buck Swader is a person who
DM'd Mantis to for to try to paint me as a suspect as well uh
to get her logs to paint me as someone who'd been harassing Mantis
as well, right? This was an act of campaigning that they did
for a long long time to paint me as a suspect that they're still
doing to this day. But yeah, this is something that's been going
on for years. And this is a tactic that they use. Schrödinger's
joke, right? And they will make accusations, but they will do
it kind of half-jesting.
And yeah, this is what happens. So yeah, it's a it's a big tactic
tactic that Cream uses a lot. It's very popular, okay? Now, here
we go.
Step nine, and I see this happening in chat, too.
Hey Twitch, I'm looking at you. Uh you
and you minimize theirs. And what does that mean?
Anything done to you,
you paint in the maximally bad light, right? I've seen this happen
on Twitter, right? Claims by different streamers and different
people, some of them don't stream anymore, that I have uh that
I was harassing Contra. That I was harassing CounterPoints.
Right? What did I actually do? I disagreed with the way was handling
it and I confronted him about it. Is that harassment in no stretch
of the imagination? Have I been harassing counterpoints? Quite
the opposite in fact. But because I questioned, right? The people
the person that they were mind raping,
um I'm her I'm harassing counterpoints. I'm stalking counterpoints.
I'm going after counterpoints. That's the narrative that some
of them are planting, right? And they'll minimize what they do.
And you see this all the time. They're like, "Bro, we just have
a clipping >> You are minimizing
the coordinated
harassment campaign that you have built and are targeting towards
not only Destiny, Ethan Klein,
um anyone associated with them. Dude, if we could if we could
actually do like a coordinated psyop on like five different streamers
who have audiences in the or on the order of like hundreds of
thousands, if we could do all of this at the same time, then
you guys should shut the [__] up. We're like superhuman.
You guys should like actually put your head
If you really believe that you should put your head down, no?
We're We're dominating this hard with just 100 people? No shot.
them who doesn't disavow,
um that is not just we have criticisms and are expressing them.
There's a fundamental difference here. And And this is what they'll
do. When you call it out and none of the other tactics work,
they can't deflect from it, they can't distract from it, they
can't go on offense, they can't move the
They'll minimize it. And they'll minimize what happens to you,
too, right? They'll minimize
And we've talked about this before, right? But they'll minimize
what happens to you. Like all you did All I did was dox you,
bro.
And yeah, that's bad. And we disavow it. But Destiny has done
so much worse to
He doxxed us.
Double If they didn't have double standards, they wouldn't have
any standards at all. Be clear.
Um Desi started doxxing people before this Discord existed.
Ugly Moe Rat
You are so stupid. Desi was doxxing people long before this Discord
ever existed. You rat.